look
[Music]
good day jaramillo greets you
with his report today Wednesday
December 23 several churches have
their services scheduled for
Christmas Eve some temples are
ensuring security measures such as
social distancing and checking
body temperatures churches
Catholics in Las Vegas' have
face-to-face masses scheduled for Thursday
and on Sunday they will still have
virtual masses to limit the number of
people in their churches, they
are also asking members of
their parishes to make appointments before
going to the church in the southern district of
Nevada  is asking the community to
be patient with
vaccine shipments district employees
received the first shipment of the
modern vaccine consisting of 15,000 doses on
Tuesday
the distribution will be distributed first
to employees of the health sector and
medical centers for people of
seniors the health district is
considering giving them the go  Cribs several
hospitalized patients with coronavirus
but each patient's doctors are
evaluating each case and health officials
say flu or flu cases
are below normal The
South Nevada Health District
reported only five cases of the flu
to date no
deaths attributed to the disease have been reported
last year there were more than 460
cases and 10 deaths from the flu doctors
say that safety measures such
as masks and social distancing
have helped with contagion as
well as efforts  standing to
control the spread of coronavirus
and trainer nurseries if you are donating
all your Christmas trees to
workers in the public health
and first aid sector the offer is
valid until Christmas Eve and all
they have to do to receive the
tree is bring  your identification to
qualify now we move on to
the weather forecast a day
with a little cold and  wind for
Christmas Eve there will be clouds and the
temperatures will be in the
50s have a good day I am salt and
jaramillo and this was x now
[Music]